c'est d'abord le before le but force et
j'aurai comme quand tu arrives en soirée
tu vois tu sait pas encore qu'il ya il
va venir jean wilfrid noël pareil lâche
un porsche cayenne il appelle ses traces
là c'est le début ça se passe comme ça
laissez les premières infos kishon
bornes
vous avez vu ce qui se passait non non
non non non il ya une annonce regarder
que vous montrez face aux variants la
nouvelle règle des 2 m 2 m voilà c'est à
dire qu'avant on devait être distancé
d'un mètre mais aujourd'hui on va être
distancé de deux mètres à ce qu'il
paraît que le nouveau variant il saute
beaucoup plus loin le gaza champions
naturisme nouveau balayé comme à ceux au
bo autant le nouveau mario abord il est
un peu getty toit était fatigué à aller
sauter redeye
et comme as tu vois là le nouveau
variant de faire c'est une bêtise et
frère il a une carrure de ouf c'est pas
johnson le gars qui les a mais sans une
ola rudin aux stéroïdes l' insee je vais
tâcher de dire tu vas prendre ta gueule
mon frère le gars est la revanche live
sur wat en face brille le nouveau run
comme en face berry comme ça sur le dos
me va comme ça que tu le prends dans la
tronche et a alors mes jolies or
maintenant il ya un maître égale
d'angers 2 mètres égale sécurité donc
c'est fini c'était pas comme avant ou
tard à m tétreault là c'est vraiment à 2
m
ça veut dire maintenant même pour parler
un gars tu ne dis pas ça veut dire tu es
tout en boîte de nuit quoi je suis par
colonne toi cher que maintenant les gars
il va voir que des gars qui s'appelle
patrick je vous dit pourquoi
bah oui je veux dire pourquoi parce que
patrick pas si vous avez remarqué je le
dit chez vous patrick c'est pas ça
secret fermé de google patrick c'est pas
un prénom genre à qui tu vas dire des
secrets du gie jamais ça n'existe pas
frérot normalement patrick c'est le gars
est toutefois pas trim
à tripoter s'affaireront ya que les gars
commencent maintenant c'est fini c'est à
dire tu dois parler à deux mètres de la
personne c'est un truc doux c'est à dire
que les gars vont à l'entendre c'est à
dire ouais salut tu as bien quoi tu as
mal aura ça va être que des bye commun
c'est à dire les gars c'est un truc tout
le monde donnera pareil ça y retournent
le mec comme ils s'appellent
commentaires quoi c'est un truc d'autres
non mais si tout le monde va est à
parier dégâts c'est un truc de ouf alors
2 m on sait jamais ce que ça pète de
mètres allait être voir parce que c'est
vrai que c'est comme dans les amarres
est vrai je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué quand vous achetez en a pas et
il ya toujours un gars de votre famille
j'entends n'ont pas eu des torts qui
arrive et il veut faire le beau gosse et
il dit à combien dans cette pièce et
pégomas 3 m 3 m bah écoute ta pièce fait
250 matches mais j'ai acheter un appart
de 45 ouais mais vous détromper man non
mais sans déconner c'est un truc de fou
parce que deux mètres on sait pas ce que
ça paie aussi je vous montre comme ça ça
fait quoi par exemple un peu moins d'un
mètre avait 50 cm à 110,70 cela ça doit
faire joli ça doit faire entre 70 et 80
donc 2 m c'est très simple moi par
exemple je suis un mètre 95 ça va aller
mais certaines ont tant que baye famille
alors où c'est vos yeux c'est moi mais
je me dis voilà donc la égard il faut
avoir bien le compas dans l'oeil
je vous le dis voilà bon donc ça y est
c'est de mettre en maintenant ses olives
et veyran qu'il a dit au iv iran le
ministre de la